tras 14 días de cuarentena en un hotel
de wuhan los expertos de la oms
finalmente podrán emprender la
investigación del origen del virus que
causó una crisis sanitaria global la
atención entre china y eeuu hacer picado
en la misión de rastreo y ha provocado
retrasos desde que se anunció finalmente
la comisión nacional de salud china
acordó cooperación con la o ms no
obstante desde el gobierno el gigante
asiático lanzó un aviso a eeuu para
evitar interferencias políticas en la
investigación
esperamos que eeuu pueda trabajar con
china que tenga una actitud responsable
que respete los hechos y la ciencia y
que respete el duro trabajo del grupo
internacional de expertos los creadores
del origen del coi 19 lado ms para que
puedan llevar a cabo una investigación
científica del origen del coi 19 libre
de interferencias políticas siendo suya
en los 13 expertos llegaron a china el
14 de enero pero la entrada de dos de
ellos fue denegada debido a que dieron
positivo en la prueba de anticuerpos del
'hobbit' 19 desde su llegada han estado
realizando trabajo de campo conjunto con
científicos chinos por videollamada con
la finalización de la cuarentena
obligatoria se espera que ambos equipos
visiten el mercado de juanan clausurado
desde hace más de un año y otros sitios
clave de la ciudad para recolectar
información
[Música]
creo que sería bueno que la o&m se
descubriera la raíz de la pandemia y que
todos los países trabajarán para
resolverlo
pujan es el primer lugar del mundo en el
que se detectó el patógeno del virus en
2019 por lo que los resultados de la
investigación son cruciales para la
salud de toda la humanidad